one of the best-known names in US
retailing is stepping aside j-cruise CEO
Mickey Drexler is known as the merchant
Prince he made a name for himself at the
gap in the 1990s and later helped j.crew
achieved mainstream success he's also
responsible for shaping some of
America's most trusted brands like Old
Navy Banana Republic and Madewell but
for the past 10 consecutive quarters
sales at j-cruise stores have declined
the change in leadership comes about two
months after longtime executive creative
director Jenna Lyons left the company
CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is in Chicago good morning good
morning let's talk first about j.crew i
mean they've had declining sales for
years now is this a surprise the last
couple of years have been brutal this is
not a surprise and I have to say changes
have been afoot at J crew from sup for
some time now even though it hasn't been
public most notably because they've been
looking actively for CEO and
interviewing them the last few months
and people knew that inside and outside
of the industry and a lot of this change
has been driven by wick Mickey Drexler
himself who remains reportedly a 10%
shareholder of this business
melody is any retailer in fashion retail
doing well yes some are doing well for
sure for example the fast retailers are
doing well like H&M and Zara and they've
been a part of the pain at j.crew
because j.crew again Drexler has said
this is still on that old model whereas
those companies can change with customer
wins in weeks as opposed to months
Mickey Drexler melody has such a great
reputation and great history in this
business and now I'm wondering how you
think he's handling this and feeling
about this Jenna Lyons also stepped down
what can you tell us about the new
leadership
how will they turn it around well my
sources are telling me again he was
driving this change he was a very aware
that something needed to happen this is
not a story of a CEO being pushed out an
ugly board scenario at all when I'm
hearing about this new leader 25 years
in retail most recently with West Elm
which is a subsidiary
williams-sonoma where he tripled sales
albeit on a much smaller footprint they
have about 99 stores
j.crew has 575 stores and he's going in
at a very tough time for this company in
terms of their debt load and in terms of
the retail environment so he's got a
real turnaround on his hands melodies
several retailers have filed for
bankruptcy this year including pay less
you know shoes more yeah the limited
BCBG Wet Seal will j.crew filed for
bankruptcy
well they have a tough situation they
have over two billion dollars in debt
now admittedly they have two and a half
billion dollars in annual sales
supposedly they only have about 150
million dollars in cash and the interest
payments that they've made recently
they've been financing with new debt
they've got a big Dame debt payment
coming in 2019 so the job one is to live
to fight another day
and get busy is that under control just
because a private equity bought it and
therefore came with a lot of debt that
got them down in part exactly Charlie
when this company was taken private a
couple of years ago they saddled it with
a lot of debt with the belief that it
would grow and they would be able to
handle these payments and then of course
we've seen retail just have a tougher
and tougher time because of as I said
the fast retailers and because of
companies like Amazon
all right nobody still a great store
hope they can turn it on now it's a
great man and great prices thank you
Miller sure always good to see you